executives from youtube tiktok and
snapchat were grilled by senators about
what they're doing to keep children safe
online that hearing followed testimony
from a former facebook data scientist
who says instagram's photo sharing
services appears to seriously harm teens
utah senator mike lee challenged
snapchat executive jennifer stout his
staff created an account for a 15 year
old with no preferences and says what
showed up on the social media app was
wildly inappropriate for a child
tips on quote why you shouldn't go to
bars alone notices for video games that
are rated for ages 17 and up and
articles about porn stars i am
unfamiliar and i've taken notes about
what you
have said that your
account
surfaced
again that was all recommended for a 15
year old stout joining executives from
youtube and tick tock answering
questions about how their apps are
looking out for children on issues from
privacy to safety it's something they
all say they are actively working on now
there are at least two bills right now
senators are working on to protect u.s
children one would make it illegal for
social media companies to track a young
user's data the other would make social
media companies legally responsible if a
child is exploited on an app now we want
to remind you this is national cyber
security awareness month it only takes
less than a minute for someone with bad
intentions to possibly reach out to your
child on social media for ideas on how
to talk about
this with your children and for more on
what you can do at home click on our
cyber safe parent tab at eight news now
dot com